and listen I believe that God is giving
signs every day that that this world is
drawing closer to an end and here's the
thing for me is that I'm okay with that
Todd Chrisley weeks away from heading to
prison and not feeling optimistic about
the future God didn't bring us this far
to drop us off the Chrisley Knows Best
star opens up to his son Chase who fills
in for Julie on the couple's christly
confessions podcast we had a very nice
Christmas and doing the best that we can
with the situation that we have to deal
with whenever you're in a situation that
only God can fix
you just gotta lean out amen and on the
latest episode Todd claims the
spotlight's been turned up amid his
looming prison sentence I mean literally
folks flying drones over our home flying
them up to our front door and then they
chase us down the highway down the
interstate going 80 miles an hour you
know there's been so many things that
have been reported just about 99 98 of
what's been reported has been alive but
if you come at my kids then I'm gonna
drag you and from Todd's Point of View
the media's attention is giving doomsday
Vibes to 666 Society it's it's it's a
very sad cycle but how vile and terrible
our society is it could be any day that
that the Lord comes back because and
listen I believe that God is giving
signs every day it that this that this
world is drawing closer to an end and
here's the thing for me is that I'm okay
with that yeah me too I am at a place
with my with my Lord and Savior that if
God calls me home tonight if you shed a
tear you let it be a tear of joy and and
gladness that your daddy is is finally
rejoicing in peace I pray to God every
day we made that commitment I know I
made that commitment that no matter how
tough things were I was not going to
walk away Todd and Julie Chrisley report
to their Florida prisons on January 17th
where they're serving a combined 19-year
sentence but I mean it's no secret that
we have a broken system the reality of
it for me is that when you know you did
not do these things and yet you sit you
stand here convicted that's that's a
hard pill to swallow what we will not do
is we will not break I think it's
natural that you feel sorry for yourself
because you're grieving you're grieving
it's a grieving process I had to say to
Savannah I said you need to find Grace
yeah Savannah's also opened up on her
unlocked podcast thinking of mom and dad
not being here during certain life
events until I know that they're gonna
be there yeah I can't get married I
can't have a kid but despite Todd's
gloomy Outlook in the New Year Savannah
says her dad's been keeping the family
in good spirits
dab was like it doesn't if I may not be
here in front of you he was like but I'm
still alive yeah I'm still fighting I'm
still you know you don't have to live a
day without speaking to me exactly if
only people knew that things that they
did for people on a day-to-day basis
they're the two most giving people I
think I've ever met my entire life
[Music]
foreign